[موسيقى]
كنا نود كثيرا أن يكون هناك
الحد الأدنى من التعاطف من جانب هؤلاء
شركتين عندما يكون لديهم
راضٍ طوال التعليمات
ليأتي ويقول ما فعلناه هو
مثالي وهو إما خطأ
السائقين يكون خطأ سوء الحظ و
أن عائلات الضحايا لا تستطيع
لا أسمع ما تعلمته أيضا
من خلال هذه الدراما تخسر فقط
الإنسان من دمه شيء
شيء
رهيب واليوم
لا أحد يستطيع أن يحل محل الأب
أم أخ أخت وابن أ
بنت
وذلك الحزن
ذاكرة
الحزن شيء لدينا
في حد ذاته
لأجل الحياة
إنه عمر
[موسيقى]
عليك التفكير في الجميع وبعد ذلك
كل يوم يأخذ الجميع
الحياة
لذلك عليك التفكير في الآخرين أيضًا
هذا الشيء يجب أن يحدث أكثر
أبدا هو مؤلم جدا
لا يطاق لدرجة أنه هنا
يجب أيضًا محاولة الحفاظ على جميع ملفات
العالمية
[موسيقى]
من هو مؤكد
الحفلة لمن هو كبير في السن
مؤسَّسة